alors la question qui se pose
aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'on a
suffisamment de stock pour passer divers
impôts c'est oui en france et non
ailleurs donc oui en france parce qu'on
a des stocks qui sont vraiment bien
remplie mais les stocks en allemagne aux
pays bas sont vraiment pas remplies
alors c'est le verre à moitié plein ou à
moitié vide ou à moitié plein en france
normalement on va pouvoir passer l'hiver
sans trop de problèmes à moitié vide
c'est que si toute l'europe nous demande
de taper dans le stock on en aura pas
assez et là on aura un problème partout
dans le continent donc ça c'est si c'est
ce qui se passerait s'il faisait
vraiment froid et si les ruches
continuer à faire de la rétention
scénario pessimiste
pas impossible
mais c'est pas un peu physiquement c'est
pas facile
c'était impossible il faut pouvoir en
tête alors que dire d'autre sûr je pense
que j'ai brossé l'essentiel des causes
du marché du gaz il ya aussi un élément
qui me permet d'introduire le prix du
carbone c'est qu'on pourrait se dire bon
mais puisque le gaz a autant augmenter
pourquoi est-ce qu'on utilise encore
pour fabriquer l'électricité est ce
qu'il ya un certain nombre de pays en
europe la pologne ou l'allemagne qui
pourrait le fabriqué à partir du charbon
pour la bonne bouche au premier semestre
2021 l'allemagne la production
d'électricité allemande a été davantage
issue du charbon que d'énergies
renouvelables
c'est à dire qu'il ya des 23% ce roi de
l'électricité allemand de produits au
premier semestre était à partir de
limites et comme il ya eu moins de vent
joie une éolienne comme il y avait moins
de vent en mer du nord au premier
semestre merci il ya eu moins de
production d'électricité d'origine
éolienne et donc ils ont produit plus
d'élèves d'origine charbonnières que
delek de régime de nerfs je dis ça je
dis rien évidemment et pendant ce temps
là évidemment le prix du
co2 sur les quotas d'émission a beaucoup
augmenté et ça c'est structurel ça ces
structures essentiellement structurelles
c'est un peu lié à la demande et comme
le prix du quota à gaza beaucoup
augmenté que le quota que le quota de
co2 pardon a beaucoup augmenté ça
pénalise davantage de charbon de gaz que
le gaz donc on s'est retrouvé dans une
situation où même si le prix du gaz
avaient beaucoup augmenté il restait
compétitif par rapport aux prix à
l'électricité fabriqué à partir de
charbon et co2 je sais pas si je suis
par le chinois enfin voilà enfin en gros
si vous voulez l'explosion du prix du
gaz sur le marché en 2021 c'est le
résultat d'un concours de mauvaises
circonstances un peu extraordinaire
parce que si j'ajoute le prix du co2 qui
augmente plus les ruches les anglais les
pays-bas la chine les américains qui
font pas redémarrer leur train de
liquéfaction
et encore deux ou trois autres et la
demande qui rebondit parce qu'on sort de
la crise du coc vide je suis dans un
environnement où j'ai sept ou huit
facteurs qui se cumulent les uns les
autres qui sont pour l'essentiel
conjoncturel pas tous mais pour
l'essentiel est évidemment j'aboutis un
comportement du marché qui pourra les
nerfs pour amener un économise de
l'énergie qui n'est pas aberrante n'est
pas pathologique parce qu'on sait bien
que les prix l'énergie s'est il parle et
les plus volatiles de l'économie et que
quand le marché de l'électricité
fonctionne pas bien on peut avoir un
prix délai qui est multiplié par 10 en
quelques heures ça s'est déjà vu
[Musique]